الرهان يرتفع بشكل كبير على الذكاء
الاصطناعي بين شركات التكنولوجيا للحفاظ
على صدرتها اظهر تحليل اجراه مركز انتر
ريجينال الى انه من دون الاهتمام بهذا
القطاع قد تتمكن بعض الشركات الناشئه
بمفردها او بتمويل من شركات تكنولوجيه
اخرى من تقديم ابتكارات جديده تهدد عمالقه
التكنولوجيا وفقا للبيانات تحديدا عام
2021 بلغت قيمه الاستثمارات في شركات
تطوير عمليات الذكاء الاصطناعي 13 مليار
دولار وضعت شركه مايكروسوفت ما يتراوح بين
عشره مليارات وعشرين مليار دولار في شركه
اوبن اي واطلقت الشركه برنامج اي اي 4
ايرث لحمايه الكوكب من التغيرات المناخيه
شركه ميتا طورت حاسوبا عملاقا يعمل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهو الحاسوب الذي قد
يكون الاسرع عالميا شركه ابل استحوذت على
شركات متخصصه بهدف تطوير مساعدها المعروف
باسم سيري عملاق البحث الصيني ايضا شركه
بايدو كثافه استثماراته في مجال السيارات
الذاتيه القياده واطلق شركه سينس تايم
اطلقت كاميرات مراقبه ذكيه تتعقب حوادث
المرور والسيارات المتوقفه بشكل غير
قانوني
[موسيقى]